[Musique]
oh on s'était pas tant ce truc là ça
t'intéresse bien ah oui dis donc c'est
c'était pas le seul nom la faim dans la
forêt ça fait fureur à tout le moins
joué à ça dans tous les dents chaque
sapin on y joue c'est toi qui l'a
préparé c'est moi ou c'est moi qui ai
trouvé ça c'est très facile et lancé
quoi en fait c'est un serpent qui tourne
c'était ça d'ailleurs ça les a tous fait
fuir dans la forêt jetables et les
serpents à cause de ça ils ont eu peur
aulas tu veux pas le savoir alors c'est
très facile tu vois tu découpes oui tu
prends un carton tu le découpe et puis
en spirale battant je vais le montrer
louis à nos amis bonsoir bonsoir à tous
et à toutes
voilà comment vous allez faire c'est
tout quand capra préparer ce petit truc
c'est bien votre temps oui tu dit
bonsoir je me sois brice voilà alors
c'est une simple spirale dessiné sur un
carton comme vous le voyez
ensuite vous avec une paire de ciseaux
tout à fait comme envers moi je les
découpe et avec mon bec
oui la table alors une paire de ciseaux
tout simplement vous découpez cette
spirale vous la colorier ensuite comme
vous voulez voilà ce qu'a fait tout
concept assez joli c'est intéressant que
la tête du serpent au bout que vous
faites bien soigneusement et vous la
tête du serpent est là à l'autre
extrémité faut percer un petit ou alors
à la faux problème parce que très
importante où réside la bon c'est vrai
tu as raison de me le rappeler la queue
de serpent et donc au bout ici vous la
tenez avec une épingle
wen milouin cl oui c'est un peu passé un
fils une source de chaleur
là c'est une bougie c'est vrai j'y qu'on
a allumé
vous mettez bien le serpent au milieu au
dessus et au bout de quelques temps ça
tourne ça tourne fort de la chaleur ben
non ça rafik pas toi rentre quand même
mais alors ça démarre voilà ça démarre
du site c'est parce que c'est l'air
chaud qui montrent un c'est ça
exactement tout à fait ça c'est un vieux
principe mais c'était très bien
l'appliquer bravo tout quand j'irai
gravissant m6 a pu te faire plaisir j'en
suis ravi
ça me plait jamais refaire des choses
comme ça vient régulièrement au coude si
je reviens la semaine prochaine tu veux
bien que je revienne je t'en prie j'ai
encore plein de surprises pour toi à
temps j'avais je vais m'approcher de la
jeu j'essaye d'être des tonnes la bougie
de souffler mais maintenant je vais le
faire suivre en direct pendant qu'ils
n'arrivent pas bien
voilà très bien que tu as raison il faut
toujours éteindre
voilà un objet ou un feu l'enfance oui
absolument j'ai par exemple je vais te
demander de sortir maintenant moi je me
sens oui s'il te plaît mais pourquoi je
sais qu'il te plaît parce que on a une
petite surprise pour toi avec bell bell
et pousse moussu alors ce sera quelque
chose oui on a préparé bonjour monsieur
je m'emmêle tu sors tu vas dans le
jargon pas longtemps non non tu
n'écoutes pas au port non non non ça je
ne triche pas
laurence je m'en vais à tout à l'heure
il est parti dit d'où tous les deux la
chapelle wismo si vous êtes oui oui sont
alors vous vous rappelez bien de tout ce
qu'on a construit une jolie je crois
qu'il va être bon alors je reviens au
bon jour on est là bon alors didot
batteur fabrice nous allons te proposer
un petit jeu wii 2 tu vois tous les
trois rappels belles pousses boussu et
moi on va on va jouer contre toi tu à
chacun de nous va représenter quelque
chose de différent tu vois alors un
objet une plante un animal tu vois enfin
n'importe quoi mais il y aura toujours
entre nous entre ces trois objets ou ces
trois choses un point commun est déjà
compris un point commun entre vous trois
césars présentée non toi il faudrait que
tu devines ce point commun tu vas cesser
facilement parce que nos amis devront
faire exactement la même chose pendant
ce temps la réalité
bon alors battu est prêt je peux
commencer je suis prêt vous êtes prêt
également twitté prend les gens vivent à
voilà on y va bon alors qu'il augmente
c'est toi oui bon je suis une autoroute
dois je suis une autoroute une très
belle autoroute
tu vois ces autoroutes qui emmène les
automobilistes en vacances vers les
plages doit l'oceane l'autoroute de
normandie le toute l'aquitaine est alors
sur moi il ya les voitures filent à
toute vitesse tu vas au saas et des
voitures tu vois c'est des voitures ou
non mais qui ne dépassent pas la limite
permise bien sûr et puis alors tout d'un
coup elle arrive à un péage les voitures
alors la peau bon tu étais coin
techniquement tu vois il faut bien
qu'elle s'arrête pour donner des sous
aux péages
voilà à quoi mène alors moi je suis un
flacon de parfum
un très joli flacon taillé dans du
cristal que j'ai toujours avec moi dans
mon sac de temps en temps je prends
quelques gouttes du merveilleux parfum
qu'il contient je les verse sur la paume
de ma main que je promène ensuite sur
mon visage sur mon coup derrière les
oreilles surtout s'est fourré c'est
délicieux fabrice ya appris vient sortir
mam sans
ismaili on c'est merveilleux on
s'émerveille tiffenat bon à moi à moi
oui oui oui sion à une écoute pas on va
y aller pour l'instant je sais qu'il ya
une autoroute
il y à un flacon de parfum bon ben moi
j'attends pour smooth à moi moi moi je
suis un pêcheur un pêcheur à la ligne
qui s'en va chez lui de bon matin pour
aller s'installer au bord de la petite
rivière tranquille au pied d'un arbre
mais attention c'est un pêcheur très
bien équipée à j'ai tout ce qu'il faut
haribo mon client mon épuisette une
canne à pêche avec les accessoires le
moulinet des âmes sont toutes sortes
deux fils de rechange
enfin tout ce qui fait que je ne reviens
jamais bredouilles à et tu devrais venir
avec moi fabrice mais oui tu devrais
venir je te montre risque c'est un vrai
pêcheur commun entre une autoroute un
flacon en juillet un pêcheur à la ligne
[Musique]
attends je verrais bien peut-être un
rapport une autoroute il ya des files de
voitures dessus un pêcheur peut avoir un
fils évidemment mais alors un flacon de
parfum n'a pas de fils
oh là là tu m'as parlé tout à petit m'a
dit les voitures s'arrêtent au péage et
zarif tout et ça y est je ne sais pas si
vous avez trouvé parce que c'est pas
évident c'est quand même assez difficile
mais malgré tout une autoroute un flacon
de parfum et puis il m'a dit un pêcheur
à la ligne
un bouchon de voiture un bouchon joue
sur le flacon
vous aviez trouvé je sais je suis pas
enfin tous les cas bravo bravo c'était
bien à l'abri oui maintenant pouces
moussu que tu aimes bien orange larousse
moussu a préparé spécialement quelque
chose pour toi aller à toi pouces moussy
bon d'accord d'accord alors tu étais
d'accord fabrice un comble alors je te
propose un jeu voilà c'est un jeu très
simple c'est un jeu qui consiste à
deviner un mot de plusieurs lettres
alors je te donne la première et la
dernière haie et toi tu devines et nos
petits amis aussi seulement il faut que
tu es quelque chose pour écrire tu as
qu'il faut d'abord que je suis prévoyant
au cfaa raffineurs ça mais maintenant il
faut aussi un table où quelque chose
alors tu es d'accord
oui bon alors je te donne la première
lettre
c'est un mot en cette lettre dans cette
lettre cette lettre bon alors la
première lettre c1 c'est un ca c
inscrits 1 c voilà alors après tu fais
un deux trois quatre cinq petits points
ou cinq petits traits comme tu veux oui
un sens représentent les lettres et les
vins de 3,4 saint alary tirer est ultra
bien direct suis très bien tout ça est
alors la 7e c'est un put
une dernière lettre à mme la dernière
lettre et la huent bras laval alors
maintenant c'est une fête de vider et on
est devenus mes efforts je pose des
questions là bas si tu veux je te
répondrai pas
là on y va vous faites la même chose on
va travailler ensemble pour qu'on se
concentre bien ouais gaza gaza trek est
ce que c'est un aliment
oh non non non non un aliment ça se
mange pas quoi bon classement et est ce
que est ce que est ce que c'est une
couleur
non non couleur couleur c'est pas un
homme célèbre c'est pas non non non non
est ce que c'est un arbre non c'est
panalpina ça se trouve dans la forêt les
animaux est ce que c'est un animal
aa c'est un animé et oui oui qui
commence par un c qui se termine par un
nul
maintenant si tu veux je peux t'aider un
peu à peu à les battre en passant je
vais juste les dérives juste lui donner
la lettre du milieu non c'est à dire la
4e quatrième lettre est un ado russe
c'est un peu comme pouces boussu 1p rien
p voilà pour ce monsieur
alaa a maintenant tu devrais trouver
quand même principe les animaux alors
est ce que c'est un gros animal non non
il est pas très gros est ce que c'est un
animal qui courent extrêmement vite
c'est à dire que ils courent pas ils
sautent ils sautent nice haute
c'est ensuite animal oui à petit animal
qui saute
bravo petit animal qui saute et il y en
a dans la forêt oui aux jeunes temps
connais toi oui tous mes amis ce sont
des amis at war et qui commence par un c
qui sautent qui saute très haut
notons enfin ça c'est pas ma faute
est-ce que ça saute dans un endroit où
il ya de l'eau oui oui oui oui oui
alors la joie pas tu me dis un animal
qui sautent là où il ya de l'eau il ya
des grenouilles
[Musique]
pas ça peut paraître un crapaud is a
détaillé comment ça ben ben pouces
moussu au lieu de bailler aux corneilles
là tu pourras comment comment je t'écris
cra pour comment tu écris crapaud cr ape
a eu ses airs aux pays bas huit ans à se
prononcer soit oui tu as raison vous
rendez compte crapaud c est rapé a eu
mais tu es nul en orthographe monte oh
quel scandale
brooke je suis sûr que tous ceux qui
sont en train de jouer avec nous se
moque de toi en ce moment robe un
crapaud c'est râpé a eu d un crapaud
enfin toi que c'est raisonnable ça au
portable avait rectifié vous même parce
que véritablement c'était une erreur
colossale
dommage parce que c'était bien trouvé sa
chaîne fois pour la faire attention là
oui bah non ça c'est pas bien pour ce
monsieur
bon d'accord le crapaud fallait le
deviner je connaissais pas bien leur
taux gras dans le temps de lui dire toi
enfin tout con con mais je peux laisser
pas bien lors de graves de la paume
mais ce que je sais moi ce que je peux
vous dire ton raisonnement est un animal
pas méchant du tout et est très très
utile
ah ben oui oui oui j'ai beaucoup vécu
moi au milieu des crapauds je les
regardais attrapé d'un seul coup de
langue là les chenilles les limaces les
mille pattes
c'est bien simple toutes les bêtes qui
mangent des légumes les crapauds les
montrait alors il faut pas les tuer oui
faut pas les télés les crapauds l'avait
qu'on y fera attention
ouais ça c'est premier pouces vous sur
rue alors voilà alors j'ai autre chose à
présenter
oui tu connais belles belles belles
belles
moi j'en suis alors belle belle elle au
site a réservé une surprise à une
surprise musicale à langon bell bell va
chanter et ensuite ltd direct certaines
choses à deviner mais je lui laisse la
parole tu as écoute l'aller elles sont
bien là
[Musique]
pour saluer mépris des signaux passent
la nuit
il est minuit prenez vos soeurs vont
dans ce sens
je vais tourner la plus belle moto
[Musique]
bravo bon je la chante bien on peut l es
deux mois à l'est de toi oui je les
composés durant mes vacances à jour où
tout d'un coup l'inspiration ne me suis
pas comme tout à rester tendue sur une
plage à me dorer au soleil à rêves assez
dans le vide
j'ai voyagé tout fonctionne aujourd'hui
est oui bon moi je me cultive mon avis
non mais d'accord je suis tout à fait
d'accord
maintenant il ya une chose quand même
quand tu chantais tout à l'heure tu
chantes s'était enfin c'était un peu de
l'espagnol s'était tué en espagne
peut-être nous en parler oui oui enfin
j'aimerais peut-être qu'on me le demande
encore encore et je t'en supplie
rencontre nous ton voyage ne voudrais
pas parce que je suis discrète si timide
au fond une vraie violette puisque vous
insistez je sais mais c'est bon pour
vous faire plaisir personnel a fait
attention belle belle parce que moi je
suis allé en espagne et je connais bien
l'espagne ne nous raconte pas de bêtises
vous voyez
monter quand je dis toujours la vérité
enfin la presque vérité value imaginez
vous que j'hésitais entre deux moyennes
transports fallait-il prendre l'avion
fallait-il prendre le train c'est que je
tenais à poser le pied sur le sol
espagnol
au douzième coup de minuit ah bon
pourquoi ça pour contempler les salaires
le soleil de minuit que tu es digne
encore mon pauvre petit tim ferriss jeux
wii anti toi une fois pour toutes laisse
moi parler alors séville à séville est
une ville superbe des palais qui se
reflète sur les eaux du guadalquivir le
guadalquivir je te le dis au cas où tu
saurais pas c'est un fleuve à la colonne
au nombre enregistre je me souviens
d'une certaine promenade en bateau
dangereuse mais dangereuse mes amis vous
auriez pu ne pas me revoir j'ai failli
être des morts les moustiques mais non
par les crocodiles
j'en ai tué à coups de carabine bon j'ai
pas j'ai vu des courses et des taureaux
j'ai vu j'ai vu gym enfants mille choses
si je devais tout vous raconter dans le
détail la journée n'y suffirait pas le
temps a passé trop vite
la mauvaise saison est venu et il s'est
mis à neiger les traîneaux envahi les
rues il y en avait tant qu'il était
difficile de traverser sans danger
on imagine mal ce qu est un encombrement
de trento tous ces gens qui crient
attrapé un rhume
je me sens lâche quelques oh je me
retire
fabrice passe pas des veaux taille je te
prie les remorques
[Musique]
oui lâche adios dans un état elle est
dans un état c'est pas croyable très mal
elle est très malin litres mais n'a pas
très bien
moi je ne sais pas mais tu penses
certain qu'elle soit vraiment aller en
espagne
ça vous paraît n'être cette affaire-là
oui bon je le dis je me suis l'espagne
l'espagne
vous n'avez rien remarqué
d'extraordinaire dans ce qu'elle raconte
est enfin quand même le soleil de minuit
ne rechute pas un peu ça le soleil de
minuit en général c'est plutôt dans les
pays nordiques j'aurais bien le nord de
la suède ou de la norvège
enfin moment nous a dit les traîneaux le
lettré nous à séville en andalousie
comme ça la neige et les traîneaux
trouvé ça autres ça normal
oh non non on voit pas étonné sa balle
piquée ce qu'il m'a dit encore une chose
qui m'avait frappé la tuque ont contré
observateurs m par l'idée qu'est ce
qu'elle a dit elle a dit les traîneaux
et regnault et la journée le soleil de
nuit
et qu'est ce qu'elle a dit aux
crocodiles les crocodiles guadalquivir
le guadalquivir la briefer choix le
crocodile dans le bois de cuir tu
connais voilà le qui vive
ben oui bah c'est un fleuve d'europe
t'as déjà vu des crocodiles vous voulez
mon avis ça sont des cracks et liège
amélie n'a jamais mis les pieds en
espagne ça c'est authentique anglais
enfin écoute on va rien lui dire parce
que sinon elle serait vexé c'est pas la
peine et entre nous on sait poids santé
vous aviez aussi remarqué sa blessure
bon alors si ça ne t'ennuies pas tout
quand quand je devrai bien utiliser
encore le serpent que tu m'avais
préparer tout à l'heure tu sais des
trucs de physique la baseball aux pages
et bien ça me fait bien plaisir que tu
t'intéresses à ce jeu ça j'ai trouvé ça
bien fait tu mens préparant pour la
semaine pour jouer avec bell bell est
pouces mesure va t'amener de jolies
chaussures et oui ça ça me ferait
plaisir avant alors je vais le refaire
un oui tu allumes la bougie est louis
pas d'ogm éléments non parce que il faut
l'achever
de chaleur a expliqué je rappelle à nos
amis comment ça fonctionne j'ai une
simple source de chaleur là j'ai pris
une bougie secte humaine ce qu'il ya de
plus pratique
ce qui est un petit peu difficile c'est
de la mettre en route quand on est
parent doux et voilà c'est fait bon
alors le serpent vous souvenez que c'est
un simple morceau de carton qui a été
découpée en spirale et puis on le place
en principe au dessus de la source de
chaleur et au bout de quelques instants
sa doit démarrer et ça doit tourner que
la chaleur se met bien au centre du
serpent et qui n'est pas noir et blanc
il tourne bien et voilà assez formidable
cette affaire pouvait faire exactement
la même chose chez vous je vous souhaite
de le réussir
à très bientôt et vous pouvez m'écrire
pour me dire si vous avez réussi ce
petit truc là au revoir à bientôt